[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقع واحداثهم وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من رام الله بالضفه الغربيه
المحتله حيث تسود اجواء من التوتر
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي نباحات المسجد
الاقصى في القدس الشريف
ومن العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن تصلون هذه
الصور في وقت ينكب فيه مجلس النواب على
انتخاب رئيس جديد له خلفا للديمقراطيه
المستقيله نانسي لوسي
ومن سانتوس في البرازيل وولايه ساو باول
تحديدا تصل لنا هذه الصور هناك شيعت
البلاد اليوم اسطوره كره القدم بلاي الى
مثواه الاخير
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي يقتحم باحات
المسجد الاقصى وسط موجه تمديدا عربي ودولي
التلفزيون الاسرائيلي يقول ان الاقتحام
كان بالتنسيق مع رئيس الوزراء والبيت
الابيض يعلن رفضه المسافه بالوضع القائم
للاماكن المقدسه في القدس ويبدا نتنياه
للالتزام بتعهداته
بعد احالته للتحقيق مع ثلاثه من قاده
المعارضه رئيس جبهه الخلاص في تونس يرفض
الاستجابه لاي استدعاء قضائي ويعتبر
الاحاله لعبه سياسيه الرئيس سعيد يدعو
لتطهير البلاد من من قال انهم استحودوا
على خيراتها وجمعيه القضاه تدعوا للحفاظ
على استقلاليه القضاء
في اولى جلساته بعد انتخابات التجديد
النصفي مجلس النواب الامريكي يفشل في اول
تصويت الانتخاب رئيس جديد وسط خلافات في
صفوف الاغلبيه الجمهوريه
غداه اقراري موسكو بمقتل عشرات من قواتها
في دونيت كيف تعلن حاله التاهو بالجوي في
جنوب البلاد تحسبا لتصعيد روسي
دعم لندن لكيف في مواجهه الهجمات الروسيه
بالطائرات المسيره
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا ناقصنا معكم
استدعاء الزعيمي جبهه الخلاص الوطني في
تونس احمد نجيب الشابي للتحقيق ووصفه ذلك
بانه لعبه سياسيه لن تنطلي على احد وقال
شاب ان اي مخالف للراي في تونس اصبح مكانه
السجن وان الشعب يقاد بالعشرات الان امام
القضاء ياتي ذلك اثر رفع رئيسه الحزب
الدستوري عبير مرسي دعوى ضد الشابي وقد
خريف في جبهه الخلاص تتهممهم فيها بالعمل
مع شخصيات على صله بجرائم ارهابيه
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال الثالث
في المعارضه التونسيه الى التحقيق
74% قالوا انها دوافع سياسيه بينما قال
تسعه بالمئه ان الدواء قانونيه فيما ذهب
17 بالمئه الى ان الامر علقوا بفرض هيبه
الدوله
هذا السؤال لسيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم كالعاده دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا وتطرق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون معنا في الحصاد ايضا
البرازيل التطبي صفحه مشرقه من تاريخها
الرياضي لتوديع نجم كره القدم بلاي ودفنه
في مسقط راسه سانتوس
[موسيقى]
اعلنت تلفزيون الاسرائيلي ان رئيس الحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو كان على علما باقتحامي
وزير الامن القومي اثمار
زعيم الصهيونيه الدينيه المتطرفه للاقصى
متولي حقيبه الامن القومي في حكومه
نتنياهو
ليس مجرد واحدا من ابرز قاده المستوطنين
الذين كانوا يدنسون المسجد الاقصى بل
اقتحم اتامار بن كزير الحرم القدسيه
الشريف كوازيرا للامن القومي الاسرائيلي
اقتحام ضلل به الكثيرين حتى داخل اسرائيل
بعد اتفاقه مع نتنياهو وقاده الاجهزه
الامنيه على تنفيذه في الصباح الباكر ودون
طقوس دينيه
اقتحام استمر 13 دقيقه ولكن هذه الدقائق
حملت تبعات كبيره
لشعب اسرائيل ومفتوح للجميع ياتي الى هنا
المسلمون والمسيحيون واليهود في حكومه انا
عضو فيها لن يكون هناك تمييز عنصري اليهود
سيدخلون الى جبل الهيكل ونوضح لحماس اننا
لا نستسلم ولا نتراجع
تجاهل نتنياهو الحديث عن الاقتحام الذي
سبق جلسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه الاولى
بثلاث ساعات وراى ساسه ومحللون اسرائيليون
في ذلك محاوله للاعب على كافه الاوطان
قاده المعارضه الاسرائيليه نبهوا الى
التداعيات الامنيه كما رفضت السفاره
الامريكيه تغيير الواقع في القدس في ما
وصفت الدول العربيه واسلاميه الخطوه
بالاستفزازيه
القياده والفصائل الفلسطينيه حملت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه كافه التداعيه ودعت
الفلسطينيين الى التصدي لمحاولات جعل
المسجد الاقصى معبدا يهوديا
ندعو ابناء شعبنا الى التصدي لمثل هذه
الاقتحامات التي تستهدف جعل المسجد الاقصى
مع بدن يهوديه وهذا انتهاك لكل الاعراف
والقيم والاتفاقيات والقوانين الدوليه
وتعهدات اسرائيل للرئيس الامريكي ندعو
اهلا بك والمواجهه مع الاحتلال الصهيوني
في كافه ساحات الاشتباك دفاعا عن المسجد
الاقصى المبارك
قتل الطفل ادم عياد في مخيم الدهيشه في
بيت لحم واقتحام مدينه جنين واخذ مقاسات
منازل شهداء واسرى لهدمها
حضر محللون من انها قد تجعل هذا العام
اكثر دمويه من سابقه
الاسرائيلي سيكون عام قاسي جدا في فلسطين
التاريخيه كلها يعني حتى بالداخل من تلك
السياسه من سياسه بني كبير وسياسه نتنياهو
المتطرفه
اقتحام الوزير المتطرف في تمار بني كفير
للمسجد الاقصى وقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين ونصف
منازل واعتقال العشرات واقتحام مناطق عده
في الضفه الغربيه في الايام الثلاثه
الاولى من بدايه العامه جعلت الفلسطينيين
كافه اضافه الى دول عربيه وغربيه تحمل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه كامله المسؤوليه عن
تبيعات الاحداث واعتبارها المسؤوله عن
تفجر الوضع الميداني
الجزيره القدس المحتله
وكان البيت الابيض قد اعلن ان موقف واشنطن
راسخ بشان الحفاظ على الوضع القائم
واحترام الاماكن المقدسه في القدس وشدد
على ان اي اجراء احادي الجانب يقود الوضع
القائم للاماكن المقدسه في القدس غير
مقبول واكد المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي بالبيت الابيض انا واشنطن تتوقعوا
ان يفي نتنياهو التزامه بعدم تقويض الوضع
الراهني في الاماكن المقدسه بدورها قالت
القنصليه البريطانيه بالقدس انه من المهم
ان يتجنب الجميع كل الانشطه التي تؤجج
التوترات وتقود فرص السلام فيما اكدت
القنصليه الفرنسيه في القدس تمسك باريس
المطلق بالحفاظ على الوضع الراهني في
الاماكن المقدسه في القدس
ودعت الى تجنب اي بادره لتغيير الوضع
الراهن تحمل خطر التصعيد
وفي ردود الفعل على الاقتحام ايضا قال
الامين العام لحزب الله اللبناني حسن نصر
الله ان التعرض للمقدسات وللمسجد الاقصى
من قبل الاسرائيليين قد يفجر المنطقه
بكاملها ودعم نصر الله الى كبح جماح من
وصفهم بالمتطرفين تفاديا لاندلاع حرب في
المنطقه
صوت المقاومه في لبنان الى صوت كل فصائل
المقاومه في فلسطين وعقول
ان
التعرض للمسجد الاقصى وللمقدسات الاسلاميه
والمسيحيه في فلسطين وفي بيت المقدس خصوصا
من قبل هؤلاء الصهاينه لن يفجر الوضع داخل
فلسطين فقط بل قد يفجر المنطقه بكاملها
ونقول لكل الدول في العالم
وليروعات هذا الكيان الغاصب اذا كنتم لا
تريدون حربا ثانيا في المنطقه
امام ما يجري في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
عليكم ان تذبحوا جماح هؤلاء المجانين
المتطرفين المتشددين
ومعنى من رام الله الدكتور هاني المصري
مدير مركز مسارات لابحاث السياسه السياسات
ومن الخليل العادل شديد الباحث المختص
بشان الاسرائيلي اهلا بكما نبدا بالدكتور
هاني المصري
ما المنتظر الان فلسطينيا في ضوئي ما جرى
اليوم
المتوقع
استمرار الردود النمطيه التي تكتفي
بالادانه والشجب ومناشده المجتمع الدولي
للتحرك لحمايه الشعب الفلسطيني
وعدم اتخاذ اجراءات في مستوى التحدي
والخطر رغم ان الجميع يتحدث عن الخطر ولكن
العمل ليس بمستوى هذا الحديث على الاطلاق
اذا لم يسارع الفلسطينيون ل- رد بمستوى
الخطر من خلال اولا المتابعه الى الوحده
الوطنيه على اساس برنامج سياسي كفاحي قادر
على عزل ومقاطعه هذه الحكومه والمطالبه
باسقاطها واسقاط برنامجها والعمل من اجل
تشكيل جبهه عالميه لاسقاط الاستعمار
والاحتلال والابارتيد هذا هو الرد المتوقع
والضروري وتوحيد الشعب الفلسطيني هو
الخطوه التاليه لتوحيد الفصائل والقيادات
لان الشعب الفلسطيني مستعد للصم مستعد
للمقاومه ولكن لا يجد الاستجابه السياسيه
والقياديه والبرنامجيه المناسبه من
القيادات والقوه لان الانقسام يستنزف
الطاقات الفلسطينيه ويشتت يعني العمل
الفلسطيني العظيم الذي يقوم هناك صمود من
الشعب الفلسطيني وهناك مقاومه ولكن ليس
ضمن قياده ليس ضمن برنامج ليس ضمن الافق
واضح وبالتالي لا تراكم انجازات ميدانيه
لا تراكم انجازات سياسيه وهذا لا يؤدي الى
التقدم الى الامام في وقت تزداد في
اسرائيل في التطرف والعنصريه وطرحت
الحكومه الاسرائيليه برنامجا يمكن تسميته
بكل بساطه برنامج الضم بدون استخدام كلمه
نعم برنامج بالنسبه للمستوى الاسرائيلي
بعد اذنك الدكتور هاني المصري نسال السيد
عادل شديد عن المستوى الاسرائيلي لان اخر
تصريح لئير نبيل رئيس الحكومه السابق وصف
ما جرى بانه عدم مسؤوليه سياسيه وضعف لا
يصدق من جانب رئيس الحكومه نتنياهو امام
وزراء الى اي مدى هذا الراي يمكن ان يكون
يعني منتشرا في الراي العام الاسرائيلي
مساء الخير لك ولضيفها كل الاستاذ هاني
وللمشاهدين اولا اهلا وسهلا
[موسيقى]
يعكس مسالتين الاولى طبيعه المناك في
القائمه طالما هو اليوم يمثل راس المعارضه
في اسرائيل ثم لا شك انه هنالك خشيه في في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي هو تحديدا المجتمع
الذي ينتمي اليه الى الاكيد وخاصه الشريحه
الغربيه بانه الحكومه الحاليه ستدخل
المنطقه
مظلم له اول ولا اخر له ولكن
موقف ليس موقف اخلاقي ولا مبدئي بالعكس
يعني بالفتره فتره الحكومه السابقه التي
كانت اكثر سنه يقتحم فيها مستوطنين يهود
متدينين المسجد الاقصى تجاوز عدد اليهود
الذين اقتحموا الاقصى بالعام الماضي
51 الف مقارنه بالسنه التي سبقتها بضل
فتره اخر ايام حكومه نتنياهو اللي لم
تتجاوز ال 34 اييه الف بمعنى انه انه
المعارضه الاسرائيليه اليوم غير قادره على
اسقاط هذه الحكومه هذه الحكومه لها همم
يعني 64 مقعد بالكنيست اكثريه همم متماسكه
برنامج سياسي واضح ما حدث اليوم من اقتحام
لبن كثير للمسجد الاقصى لم يكن كما يتوقع
البعض حدثا جنونيا او استعراضيا او ارضاعا
للناخب الاسرائيلي بقدر ما شكل ترجمه
وانعكاس دقيق لبرنامج الحكومه وتحديدا
برنامج اهم مركب من مركباتها القوه
اليهوديه بالزعامه
والصهيونيه الدينيه بالزعامه بتسال الايه
السموتر
في تصريحات
الاسرائيليه وانا اسال الدكتور هاني
المصري ااه التصريحات الاسرائيليه ركزت
على حماس وكان المعركه هي بين هذه الحكومه
وحماس كيف تنظر الى هذا ال- ال- الانحراف
في الحديث عن عن طبيعه الحالي
اعتقد ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه برئاسه
بنيامين نتنياهو وبمشاركه بن كثير ما رسوب
الامس عمليه خداع ومن خلال الظهور بانهم
لن يقوم بكثير باقتحام المسجد الاقصى
وتم الترويج ان هذا بسبب تهديد حماس ولان
حماس مصنفه عند الولايات المتحده وعدد من
البلدان وبالمجتمع الدولي كم تنظيم ارهابي
وبالتالي اظهار حماس في الصوره يمكن ان
يساعد الموقف الاسرائيلي وفي نفس الوقت
يعمق الانقسام لان فعلا لا يوجد موقف
فلسطيني موحد يوجد انقسام ويوجد سلطتين
فبالتالي توظيف يعني هذه المساله باقصها
يعني حد ممكن
وهذا الامر يدل على ان اسرائيل ايضا تضع
هذه الحكومه في حسبانها استدراج حماس
لمواجهه عسكريه لانهم لا يريدوا لهذه
الظاهره في قطاع غزه ان تستمر
اذا لم تلتزم بالقواعد التي تحددها
اسرائيل اذا مارست اي دعم حقيقي للصمود
والمقاومه في الضفه الغربيه او قامت
باطلاق صواريخ فهم يستعدون بمواجهه عسكريه
مستغلين التفوق العسكري الاسرائيلي ولذلك
يجب التنبه يعني من المخاطر التي تحملها
هذه الحكومه واجرى استعدادات جديه على
الارض في مواجهتها لان اي تحرك عربي او
دولي اذا لم يستند على موقف فلسطين فعال
وموحد وصلت لن يكون مجديا وسيبقى مجرد
ادانا وقلق وتحذير وهذا لا يكفي للردع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومنع التطبيق
برنامجها
رغم رغم الطابع الانتهازي سيد عادل شديد
كما سميته لتصريحات لبيد من ما قاله ايضا
في في تدوين له قال حتى يقضي بالكثير
ثلاثه عشر دقيقه في المسجد الاقصى اصبحنا
في خلاف النصف الم ااه الى اي درجه فعلا
هذا الامر دقيق نصف العالم يعارض و
بامكاني ان يفعل شيئا ما
يعني اعتقد انه حديث
يعكس حقيقه
التباين
والفروقات في وجهه نظر همم يعيدنا في دوا
بتمارب بالانجليزي حول كيف ستبدو وكيف
ستكون علاقه اسرائيل مع الخارج اذا فيه
ينتمي للصهيونيه العلمانيه التي ترى
بضروره ابقاء اسرائيل جزء مما يسمى
بالحضاره الغربيه الامريكيه والاوروبيه
بالشرق الاوسط مدرسه
لا يعني ذلك كثيرا ابن كثير ينتمي لبن
راسي دينيه عقائديه قوميه يرى بانه ارضاع
همم الذات اليهوديه ارضاع همم
ارض اسرائيل للكبرى العمودي الى التوراه
وما شابه واهم بكثير من الحصول على الرضا
الامريكي والغرب بمعنى ان معرض انك فيري
يعني تماما ما يقوم به ويعرف تماما ما
المطلوب تحقيقه وهو مدرك تماما انه اي
تصعد اي تصعيد هو الذي سيستفيد كما
الصهيوني الديني والتيار
الذي ينتمي اليه التمار بن كبير شكرا لك
عادل شديد من الخليل شكرا لك دكتور هاني
المصري من رام الله
بكثير الذي اقتحم باحات المسجد الاقصى من
هو وما هي ابرز محطاته التي جابت احبابا
دينيه متطرفه وصولا الى توله منصب وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
اثمار بن كثير وزير الامن القوميه
الاسرائيلي ينتمي لليمين الديني المتطرف
ويتراس حزب العظمه اليهوديه وشارك اكثر من
مره في عمليه اقتحام للمسجد الاقصى ولد
بالقدس المحتله فيما يغير عام 76 وهو من
سكان مستوطنه كريات اربع المقامه على ارض
الخليل جنوبيه الضفه الغربيه بدا نشاطه في
الاحزاب المتطرفه في سن السادسه عشر في
حزب مولده مرورا بحركه بزعامه المتطرف
ماركه هنا وصولان الى حزب الصهيونيه
الدينيه الذي ادخله الى الكنيست في ابريل
2020 حاول الانضمام الى نقابه المحامين
لكن الطلبه بسبب سجله الجنائي وتمرضه في
انشطه لليمين المتطرف وسومح له لاحقا في
بفكره ان العرب في فلسطين اعداء يجب
اخراجهم بالعنف ولا يقبل التعايش معهم
اشتهر بوضعه على جدار منزله لصوره
طيب منفذي مجزره الحرم الابراهيمي التي
راح ضحيتها 10 المصلين ووصفه بالبطل ثم
ازالها لترشح لعضويه الكنيست كما اذن
بالتحريض على العنصريه واستمر في تمثيل
مستوطننا متورطين في بناء مستوطنه غير
قانونيه وسماهم ملح الارض ودافع في 2015
عن مراهقين اتهم بالمشاركه في حادثه حرق
متعمده لافراد عائله دوابشه بقريه دوما
اقتحم بمعيه مستوطنين مره عند حي الشيخ
جراح وتسبب في تفجير الوضع فيه وفي القدس
اكثر من 50 مره بارتكاب اشكال مختلفه من
التحريض لكن كانت تتمراته في كل مره
الولايات المتحده نددت بمشاركه
من تكريم للحامل المتطرف فيما اركانه
قال عن اداره ايضا انها لن تتعامل مع بنت
فير وزيرا في الحكومه رائدتي الجديده
في فقره المتابعه ستكون لنا عوده
لاقتحابات المسجد الاقصى المبارك وما ترتب
عليها سياسيا وعسكريا
[موسيقى]
في تونس وصف احمد نجيب الشابي رئيس جبهه
الخلاصه المعارضه بحالته مع عددا من قاده
الجبهه للقضاء وصفه باللعبه السياسيه
معلنا انه لن يستجيب لاي استدعاء قضائي من
جهته شدد الرئيس التونسي قيسي سعيد على
ضروره ما وصفه بتطهير البلاد من كل من
استولى على مقدرتها
اريد ان نخرج اسماء جديده
امام القضاء للتحقيق معهم بتهم وصفت
بثقيله ضمت هذه المره ابرز قيادات جبهه
الخلاص الوطنيه من غير المنتمين الى حركه
النهضه وعلى راسها رئيس الجبهه احمد نجيب
الشابي والمحامي نظام الحاج وجوهر بن بارق
وشيماء عيسى وعلى الرغم من كون قضيه رفعت
من قبل الحزب الدستوري الحره الا ان سرعه
الاجراءات دفعت الشاب الى اعتبار ما قامت
به السلطه السياسيه
لن نلعب هذه اللعبه نقول للسلطه السياسيه
التي وظفت هذه الشكايه
التي وظفت هذه الشكايه فان لعبه التبكي
مكشوفه واكدا رفضه اقحام القضاء في
النزاعات السياسيه وتوظيفه للضغط على
المعارضين ده الحزب الجمهوري الحقوقيين
والديمقراطيين الى التجند للدفاع عن
المكتسبات الديمقراطيه والقيام بحمله
وطنيه لدحر للقلاب واسقاته العياشي
الهمامي وهو منسق هيئه الدفاع عن القضاه
الذين اعفاهم الرئيس قيس سعيد اكد بدوري
ان القضاء فتح تحقيقا ضده بتهمه بث
شائعاته من شانها الاضرار بالامن العام
كذلك الحال بالنسبه الى الامين العام
السابق لحزب التيار الديمقراطيه غازي
الشواشي وعميد المحامين السابق عبد الرزاق
الكيلاني الزمالك
الخلق
لازم لو طلبوا المعالج القضائيه والسياسيه
لاي ملف تؤدي الى ان تتداخل الامور بعضها
البعض حديث الرئيس على انه لديه ملفات اي
ملف قضائي هو ملف شبهه
وليس ملف اذن
الاخير مع رئيس المجلس الاعلى المؤقت
للقضاء شدد قيس سعيد على ضروره تطهير
البلاد من كل من استولى على مقدراتها
ويسعى الى التسلل الى مؤسساتها متهما
اطرافا لم يسميها بالتحالف مع اي جهه كانت
للوصول الى اهدافها مع اعتقادهم انهم فوق
اي مسائله او عقاب وهو ما عدتهاما مباشره
لخصومه السياسيين وتوعد منه بملاحقتهم
قضائيه
المعركه السياسيه الى اروقه المحاكم خطوه
متقدمه للاجهزه على الديمقراطيه وتكريس
استفراد الرئيسي بالحكم فيما يفدد سعيد
جميعا هذه المقولات ويتهم قضاه بالتواطئ
والتباطؤ في حسن قضايا تمثل من وجهه نظره
مدخلا ضروريا لتطهير البلاد
الجزيره تونس
وانا من تونس عبر الهاتف احمد امام
المتحدث الرسمي باسم تحالف احرار في
انتظار ابي ينضم الينا من تونس ايضا عبد
اللطيف المكي الوزير السابق والقيادي في
جبهه الخلاص سيد همام اهلا وسهلا بك
بعد ايام قليله من خطاب الرئيس قيس سعيد
الذي تحدث فيه عن ان تونس تتسع للجميع
وتحدث بلهجه تصالحيه ما الذي حصل حتى يقعى
مثل هذا الهجوم القضائي بين قوسين على
قاده في المعارضه
شكرا لكان مساء الورد لك ولجميع مشاهديكم
ومتابعي جزيره خلينا نقول كل مره يعني
يتهمون الرئيس ويتهمون السلطه القائمه
بتحريك القضايا ولكن لا نرى في ذلك في
غريب جدا يعني هذا ما ينفعنيه بالافتراء
لان من رفع القضيه على جبهه الخراف هي
الاستاذه المحاميه ورئيسه الحزب السوري
الحر عبد المنوفي وهناء لاحظنا انه الناس
تقول لماذا همم في الزمن القضائي هذا من
شمال من من مشمولات يعني وزاره العدل
والنيابه العموميه وقد التحقيق وليس
الجمهوريه في انه سيحرك ملفات دون اخرى
الى ذلك اضخم واكثر وتورط اكثر بعض
المعادين للرئيس سعيد
لكن لم يتدخل فيها رئيس قيس سعيد ولم يتعد
يتدخل في زمنها القضائي اذا لن ينطل يعني
الشعب التونسي هي مثل هذه التهمه الباهيه
البهتانا وتخلينا نقول والترتقي اصلا ل-
همم يعني الى الهزل
وتصريح نجيب الشيبي كان غريب جدا جدا جدا
عند ما يهدد القضاه مباشره لتهديد واضحا
بقوله انه لم يخضع للقضاء وايضا يهددهم
بالمحاسبه والملاحقه زي ما بعد وهذا خطير
جدا
واستغربه من نجيب الشيبي وهذا الرمز
النظام الذي كنا نعتبره رمضانيه همم
استغربنا جدا مثل هذه تصريحات نعم نعم
بعد اذنك يعني بعد اذنك اثرت الى السيده
عبير موسي وقلت بان القضيه مرفوعه من قبل
عبير موسي وهي همم رئيسه ال- ال-
الحزب الدستوري
ويعني من انصار النظام السابقون اسال
السيد عبد اللطيف مكي حول هذه النقطه لان
السيده عبير موسي كانت متهمه من قبل خصومه
على ان ساهمت في تعفين العمل داخل مجلس
النواب السابق حتى حلم الان ما دورها في
ما يجري
كم همم
لعمله واحده
مدرستان شعبويهتان لا تؤمنين بالحريه ولا
بديمقراطيه الخطاب الاقصائيه يصل الى حد
استعمال الفاظ التطهير واا ليست هذه المره
الاولى التي يتم فيها تقاسم ادوار
بصوره موضوعيه او ربما حتى في صوره عضويه
بين عبير موسى
انقلابه بتعافر الى اوضاع داخل البرلمان
وكانت هي تلعب في الدوري الاول في تعزيه
الاوضاع داخل البرنامج
جديد ولكن
الدوله التي يزج بها
بالمعارضه في محاكمات وانما هذه يتعلق لان
ما ذكرته عبير موسي في همم وشايتها هي ان
جابت الخلاصه تتكون من احد في العالم
عايزه تشكل تحالفات من الاحزاب ومن اجل
مهمه معينه انتخابيه او غير ذلك
وتحقق ذلك اي تراخيص من السلطات او اي
اجراءات قانونيه هي تقاليد في العمل اساسي
لماذا يقبل القضاء باني وفاء الى هذه
الحكايه وهي لا
تتوفر فيها اجل شبه التهام انها استغلال
الفراس واستمرار للمحاكمات السيد سعيد ليس
بحاجه الى شيء تعبير موسي ولكن اراد ان
يرسم هذه الصوره بانه بريء من المحاكمه
يعني بعد اذنك على ذكر الرئيس السيد اسال
السيد همام الرئيس السيد سعيد اشار اليوم
بان لا احد فوق القانون هكذا قال اذا في
هذه الحاله كيف نفسر ان المحكمه الاداريه
وهي المحكمه التي تنظر في قرارات الاداره
التونسيه نقدت وضحكت احاله قضاه على همم
المعاش او اعفائهم في حين لم تلتزم
الحكومه بذلك لا وزيره العدل ولا رئيس
الدوله هل من تفسير
يعني ليست بالطريقه التي رسمتها هذا
الصوره بمثل هذا المحكمه الاداريه قمت
بايقاف التنفيذ في احكام العزل بعض من 57
والحكومه لم توقف التنفيذ بل اثرت عليه
والحكومه يعني
امرت
بالايقاف التنفيذ وانت صحيح لكن الحكومه
لم تعرها اهتماما
تفضل شكرا
وايقاف التنفيذ لا يعني ارجعهم الى العمل
الوقفي هم يكون لديهم يعني ملفات لدى
القضاء ال- ال- العدلي يعني هذه هذه
الملفات هذه الملفات الحقت الحاقا بهم
عندما احيلوا لم تكن لديهم قضايا كل حلقات
بهم لاحقا
لا ليس راي هذه الوقائعه همام سيدنا همام
سيد همام دعنا لا نختلف حول
اسمح لي اسمح لي انت انا نلعب دور مذيع
وانت تلعب دور ضيف يعني خليني خليني نسالك
خليني نسالك يا سيد همي وبعد الجو خليني
خليني نسالك وبعدين انت جاوب لا
خليني نسالك وبعد جو مش مش هاربين احنا
مشاربين احنا مشاربين خلينا نسالك وبعد
تفضل جوه القضايا التي تشير اليها لانها
لا لا لا لا نتلاعب بالحقائق القضايا التي
تشير اليها فيما يتعلق بالقضاه كل
الحقيقات فيما بعد وليس ولم تكون متعلقه
بهم تفضل الان
شكرا واتمنى ان اخذ وقتي ولا اتنقاطعه
اكثر من مره اخرى
اشياء غير صحيحه تقاطع عندما تذكر اشياء
غير صحيحه
تفضل تفضل تفضل
الحكومه
برجهم ام بعدم ارجعهم وان كان لديه ملفات
اداريه تفقديه العامه لوزاره العدل وهناك
لتفقوده في يعني هناك
ملفات داخل وزاره العدل بالمنطقه العامه
فلا يطبق لانه هناك اجراء
نقرا
سيد عبد اللطيف المكي فيما يتهم به تتهم
به الحكومه والرئيس سعيد من توظيف القضاء
في المعارك السياسيه
[موسيقى]
القول بان الحكومه لديها الحق بان تريد
وهو باطل عقلهم باطل ومن له الحق في ايقاف
القضاه عن العمال هو العمل
هو فسيلقي سعيد لم يحترم حتى المجلس
الاعلى القضاء الذين اصابه هو
رئيس دوله اكثر رئيس جمهوريه في تونس قابل
وزراء العدل والداخليه والضغط عليه
وبالامس فقد
كان اص
ابعوا مارسوا عليه ضغوطات بان يتحرك
القضاء ضدها
على القضاء شكرا من اني ورده في القضاء
والى اليوم السيد قيس عايد لم يمضي الحركه
القائله التي هي ضروريه في اطار ممارسه
الضغوط شكرا لك سيد عبد اللطيف المكي شكرا
لك سيد احمد امامي
[موسيقى]
يوصلوا مجلس النواب الامريكيه التصويت في
اولى جلساته على انتخابي رئيس جديد له وقد
اخفق المجلس في انتخاب كيف المارتي زعيم
الاغلبيه الجمهوريه رئيسا للمجلس في
الجوله الثانيه للاقتراع كذلك وتعارض
مجموعه صغيره من الجمهوريين المقربين من
ترامب انتخابات مكارتي
وادي صور مباشره مباشره تاتينا الان من
هذه الجلسه التي اشرنا اليها وتنضم الينا
من الكونجرس مراسلتنا بيسين بيسان ابو
الكويت بيسان ما اخر ما يجري هناك
محمد طبعا
الثانيه ولكن مع انتهاء التصويت الان حكيم
جافريز زعيم الديمقراطيين في المجلس بشكل
طبعا غير متوقع ولا المره الثانيه يحصل
على اغلبي على 212 صوتا وهؤلاء جميع اصوات
الديمقراطيين كاظم
وهناك 19 جمهوريا يعارضون وقعت كانوا
صوتوا لعده مرشحين في الجوله الاولى الان
صوت جميعهم لمرشح واحد وهو نائب الجمهوريه
ولكن ااه الفائز يجب ان يحصل على 218 صوتا
حتى اللحظه لم يتوفر ذلك الامر لذا في هذه
الجوله لا يوجد فائز برئاسه المجلس الان
نحن امام معركه من يرمش اولا او ربما
ماركت تكسير العظام هل سينسحب مقاسي ام هل
سينسحب جودا جودا اصلا هو نفسه كان قد صوت
لمقاربي لكن هناك مرشحه لرئاسه المجلس 19
جمهوريا الان يعلقون عمليه الرئاسه يعلقون
عمل مجلس النواب باكمله ما لم يتم التصويت
على رئيس للمجلس ستبقى الامور معطله لن
يكون هناك اي تشريعات لن يكون هناك اي اا
جلسات استماع لللجان حتى عمليه انتقاء
اعضاء اللجان لن تتم ورئاستها الى ان
ينتهي هذا التصويت هذه المره الاولى منذ
100 عام يحدث هذا الامر في المره الماضيه
عام
1923 كان هناك تسع جولات تصويت قبل ان
ينتهي المطاف بتوافق على مرشح فاز في
النهايه برئاسه المجلس في عام
1856 الامور طالت لما دار شهرين
133 جوله تصفيه قبل ان يرث ترسى الامور
على همم مرشح حينها فاز برئاسه مجلس النوا
طبعا لا احد يتوقع ان تستمر الامور هنا
الى شهرين ولكن هنا التكهنات هي ما هي
الرساله التي ترسل لي العالم والان نصنع
بعض التحليلات التي تتحدث عن ذلك والى
داخل الامريكي بان الجمهوريين الذين الان
تولوا او حصلوا على اغلبيه مجلس النواب
غير قادرين على التوافق فيما بينهم على
شخص يتراس مجلس النواب ويمضي قدما
بالاجنده ان تشريعيه التي كانوا قد وعدوا
بها طبعا هناك في هذا المجلس يتوعد
بتحقيقات همم لها علاقه باداره امور لها
علاقه الصين بفيروس كورونا امور متعدده
ولكن كل ذلك لن يحدث ما لم يتم التوافق
الان اتوقعات هي اننا سندخل الى جوله
ثالثه اذا ضلت الامور على ما هي عليه الان
التصويت لجين جولدن ب 19
مرشح عفوا صوت واولائك التسعه عشر هم سيظل
المعرقلين لهذه العمليه
سيكون هناك تنازلات الهل ااه سيتم اقناع
مقاسي لسحب همم ترشحه همم لا نعلم حتى
اللحظه يعني هي بالفعل لحظه تاريخيه محمد
غير مسبوقه وصوره مشوشه وغير واضحه ولا
احد يعلم ما هو البديل ومن هو المرشح
البديل كان الحديث يتم عن ستيف كاليس وهو
الشخص الثاني بعد مقالته في قياده
الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب ولكن كنيس ايضا
سيطار لتقديم تنازلات لاولئك التسعه 19
جمهوريا الذين عارضوا مقارنه انس كاليس
نفسه يعني خطه يشبه مقاسي فهل سيكون اولئك
المحسوبين على الجناح اليمين في الحسبه
الجمهوري هم الان من يسيطرون على الامور
في مجلس عدد اعضاء
434 عضوان الديمقراطيون من الجهه الاخرى
يبدو موحدين همم في الصف همم
يصوطون بشكل نعمل لمرشحهم الذي ليس لديهم
طبعا بما ان عددهم 212 همم ديمقراطيا في
مجلس النواب فهم ليس لديهم اصوات كافيه
لتامين مثلا او قلب النتيجه بكاء لكي يكون
الديمقراطي هو من يتراس المجلس رغم
الاغلبيه الجمهوريه لذا على الاغلب سنذهب
الى جوله ثالثه ربما رابعه وخامسه ربما
يستمر هذا الامر الى ايام الى ان ايه يعني
يتولى احد الاطراف او يقوم احد الاطراف
بخطوه شكرا
فيها مرشح قد ينال توافق الجميع او يكون
هناك بعض التنازلات والمساومه
اذا اخفق مجلس النواب الامريكي في انتخاب
رئيس جديد له من الدوره الاولى بعد ما
تعذر على النائب الجمهوريه عن ولايه
كاليفورنيا كيفن كانت مكارتي الحصول على
اغلبيه الاصوات وهذه هي المره الاولى منذ
نحو عام التي سيحتاج فيها مجلس النواب
الامريكي الى جلسات عده لاختيار رئيسه مما
يعكس حجم الخلافات في صفوف الحزب الجمهوري
الذي فاز بالاغلبيه في المجلس بعد
انتخابات التجديد النصفي في نوفمبر تشرين
الثاني الماضي
منتصر
صحيح ان نتائج انتخابات تجديد النصفي في
نوفمبر الماضي ابقت الغالبيه في مجلس
الشيوخ في ايدي الديمقراطيين لكن الاقتراع
افضل ايضا الى سيطره الجمهوريين وان
باغلبيه ضئيله على مجلس النواب
218 مقعدا في المجلس المكون من 435
من مبنى الكابيتول الشهير سيعمل النواب
الجمهوريون حتما على تعقيد مهمه الرئيس
جودا
يتحدثون من الان عن استعدادهم لمنعطف
سياسي بعد ما يصفونه بعامين كارثين تحت
قياده الحزب الديمقراطي تلك معركه تسبقها
اخرى فعلى الجمهوريين اولا تجاوز
الانقسامات العميقه في صفوفهم والتوافق
على رئيس جديد لمجلس النواب الذي يتولنا
زيماء مقيادته يتعلق الامر بثالث اهم
شخصيه في المشهد السياسي الامريكي بعد
الرئيس ونائبه وذاك منصب يامل
الظفر به بعد مرور سبعه اعوام على محاولته
الاولى لقيادته الكتله الجمهوريه في مجلس
النواب
وفي غمره احتدام السجال في البيت الجمهوري
بدا ان موقع النائب عن كاليفورنيا قد
تراجع بسبب الاداء الضعيف للجمهوريين في
انتخابات منتصف الولايه فالموجه الكاسحه
التي توقعها المحافظون لم تتحقق اما اكثر
ما يخشاه مكارثي ربما فهو ان يصطدم طموحه
بتمرد الجناح اليمني للحزب المؤيد للرئيس
السابق
هل يضيق بذلك اذا هامشه للمناره ربما لكن
في غياب منافس جدي يصبح كل شيء ممكن
حاليا
في اخر عامين من ولايته الاولى ما اعقدها
من معادله فما اعتمتع الجمهوريين
بالاغلبيه في مجلس النواب لن يتمكن جوبا
ايضا وحزبه من تمرير مشاريع كبرى جديده
لكن مع سيطره الديمقراطيين على مجلس
الشيوخ لن يتمكن خصومهم من الامر نفسه
قلت قبل قليل ان مجلس النواب الامريكيه
يفشل في انتخاب رئيس الجديد له لاول مره
منذ عام والحقيقه لاول مره منذ 100 عام
فرق بين العام و100 عام معذره في تطوراتي
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اعلن الجيش
الاوكرانيه حاله التاهب الجوي في مقاطعه
جنوب البلاد وقد قالت الاستخبارات
العسكريه في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه تحاول تنفيذ هجمات جديده
واسعه النطاق على عمومه اوكرانيا
من جانبي قال الناطقه باسمي وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ايجور كناشينكوف ان القوات
الروسيه تتواصلوا مهاجمه محور دونتسك
رين اوكرانيا في محور كوبيننسكي الى جانب
مجموعتي استطلاع الاوكرانيتين بمقاطعه
خايف وفي محور كلاسني لمن سقط اكثر من 120
جراه
كما تستمر قوتنا في مهاجمه محور وقضت على
نحو 90 عسكريا اوكرانيا اما سلاح الجوي
فقد قضى على اكثر من 130 من المرتزقه
الاجانب في مدينه كرامته
افاده مراسل الجزيره في اقليم دون باس ان
الجيش الروسي استهدف بعشرات الصواريخ
والطائرات المسيره عده مدن رئيسيه في
مقاطعه الدونات في الاوكرانيه يوم امس
واضاف المراسل ان الجيش الروسي استهدف
بصاروخ 300 احد المواقع في المقاطعه ما
اسفر عن اضرار ماديه كبيره ونقل مراسلنا
عن قاده ميدانيين في الجيش الاوكراني ان
الجيش الروسي نفذ هذه الهجمات بعد الخسائر
التي تكبدها على يد الجيش الاوكراني في
مدينه
سياسيا قال الرئيس الاوكراني انه اجرم
محادثات مع رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي
سوناك ناقشه خلالها تعزيز التعاون الدفاعي
بين بلاده والمملكه المتحده واوضح زلانسي
في انه اتفق مع سوناك على تكثيف الجهود
الاقتراب من النصر الذي بات اقرب هذا
العام وفق تعبيره من جانبها قالت الحكومه
البريطانيه ان هناك ناقشه مع زيلانسك
الهجمات الروسيه بالطائرات المسيره واكد
له دعم لندن لكيف على المدى البعيد
[موسيقى]
الامين العام لحزب الله اللبناني حسن نصر
الله ان من ينتظر المفاوضات الايرانيه
الامريكيه بشان الملف النووي لانتخاب رئيس
جديد في لبنان فقد ينتظر عشرات السنوات
واضافه نصر الله ان انتظار توافق سعودي
ايراني يعني عدم انتخابي رئيسا للبنان
مشددا على ضروره اجراء حوار داخلي بين
القوى السياسيه اللبنانيه بشان ملف
الرئاسه وعدم انتظار تدخل خارجي
اللي قاعد ناطر
مفاوضات النوويه بين ايران وامريكا معناته
بدو ينط ومش بس شهر
اثنين يبقى بلاويين ايضا من ينتظرون
توافقا سعوديا ايرانيا
كمان انتم كثير ناطرين ومطولين
معناته
اتفاق سعودي ايراني
المزيد من الحوار المزيد من اللقاء وانا
اقول لكم لا تنتظروا الخارج
في السودان قال مصدراني مطلعان للجزيره ان
المكونه العسكري وقوه الحريه والتغيير
مجموعه المجلس المركزي ومجموعه الكتله
الديمقراطيه اتفقوا على توقيع اعلان جديد
لتجاوزوا معضله الاتفاق السياسي الايطالي
الموقعه في الخامس من ديسمبر الماضي والذي
لقي معارضه بعض القوى السياسيه
واكد المصدر ان الاتفاق الجديد جاء عقب
اجتماعين للبرهان مع ممثلين على المجلس
المركزي وعن الكتله الديمقراطيه اسفرها عن
تكوين لجنه مشتركه وتعقد اللجنه اليوم
اجتماعا يحسم الخلافه بشان تسميه الوثيقه
الجديده
تشهد شبكه القطارات في اكبر ثلاثه اقاليم
في المملكه المتحده شللا كبيرا في اول يوم
عمل في العام الجديد ويعود اكثر من 40,000
من العاملين في شركات تشغيل القطارات الى
الاضراب اليوم وغدا ما ادى الى الغاء اربع
من كل خمس رحلات على شبكه القطارات وتشهد
بريطانيا ايضا عوده للاضرابات من قبل
المشرفين على اختبارات قياده السيارات
والعاملين في اداره الطرق السريعه في
مناطق عده
شيعه شيعه في مدينه سانتوس البرازيليه
جنازه اسطوره كره القدم الراحل بلاي بعد
ان بقيت في ملعب فريق سانتوس
للقاء النظره الاخيره على جثمانها وشارك
في تشييع الجنازه الرئيس البرازيلي
ايناسيو لولا ذا سيلفا وقد توفي فيليه عن
عمر نهزه 82 عاما بعد صراعا مع مرض سرطان
القولون
[موسيقى]
نعود الان الى واقعه اقتحام بن كثير لباحه
المسجد الاقصى لنصليه الضوء على مكانه
الاقصى الدينيه والتاريخيه
بدا بناء المسجد الاقصى في القرن السابع
بعد فتح القدس في عهد الخليفه عمر بن
الخطاب وهو اولى القبلتين وثالث الحرمين
الشريفين بعد المسجد الحرام بمكه المكرمه
والمسجد النبوي الشريف في مدينه المنوره
في جهه الجنوبيه الشرقيه من مدينه القدس
القديمه المحتله ويحده غربا حائط البراق
او ما يسميه اليهود بحائط المبكبكه
يقصد بالمسجد الاقصى كل ما هو داخل السور
الباحث والجامعه القبلي وقبه الصخره
والمصلى المروانيه ومصلى باب الرحمه
والمرورقه والقباب وغيره كل ذلك يسمى عند
المسلمين الحرم القدسيه الشريف ويعتقد
اليهود انا ما يسمونه الهيكل مدفون تحت
الحرم القدسي وتسعى بعضه جماعتهم المتطرفه
لاعاده
اقصى اذا هو احد ابرز عناوين الصراع وقد
تعرض منذ الاحتلال
احتلال فلسطين الاعتداءات اسرائيليه
متلاحقه ففي عام 69 اشعل متطرف يهودي
حريقا في الاقصى ادى الى احتراق الجامعه
القبلي ومنبر صلاح الدين وفي عام
1996 اعلنت حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو فتحه
نفق ضخم تحت باحات الاقصى يبلغ طوله نحو
450 متر واواخر سبتمبر ايلول عام اقتحمها
زعيم اليمين الاسرائيلي حين اريال شارون
باحه المسجد الاقصى تحت حراسه قوات
الاحتلال وفجر ذلك شراره الانتفاضه
الفلسطينيه الثانيه انتفاضه الاقصى
وفي يوليو 2017 حاولت السلطات الاسرائيليه
نصب بوابات الكترونيه عند مداخل الحرم
القدسي لكن تصديا الفلسطينيين افشل هذا
المشروع وفي مايو ايار عام 2021 ادت
مواجهات عنيفه بين قوات الاحتلال
والفلسطينيين في باحات الاقصى الى اندلاع
حرب من استمرت 11 يوما بين اسرائيل وحركه
حماس التي قصفت مواقع اسرائيليه في القدس
بالصواريخ لاول مره
من القدس الشيخ ناجح بكرات نائب مدير عام
الاوقاف الاسلاميه في القدس اهلا وسهلا بك
شيخ بكيرات ما المطلوب الان اسلاميا
وعربيا بعد الذي جرى اليوم
يعني علينا ان ندرك تماما بان ما جرى
اليوم هو ااا محاوله استعراض عضلات من
اليمين المتطرف بالتنسيق مع حكومه نتنياهو
رغم نفي الخقانيه وارسال رساله كونه
للخاميه تعتمد ان يحرم على اليهود دخول
كامل ما هو في داخل السور وهناك يا خطات
علقت منذ عام
تمنع وتحرم على اليهود دخول منطقه المسجد
الاقصى بكامله بكامل مساحته 144000 متر
مربع الا ان هنا قفز على هذه الفتوى من
قبل الصهيونيه العالميه التي استغلت الدين
من اجل تحقيق ثلاثه اهداف الهدف الاول هو
تغيير الرؤيه البصريه في المدينه التي
يسعى الاحتلال الى جعل القدس كعاصمه وديها
لمشروع الدوله اليهوديه ولابد من تغيير
هذا هذه الرؤيه التي تعطيك بان الطابع هو
طابع اسلامي منذ زمن ادم وورثه الانبياء
يعني حينما صلى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
بهذا المكان والانبياء جميعا بايعوا النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم واعطوه هذه الامانه
والنبي نقل هذه الامانه الى الصحابه الذين
كلفتهم اكثر من 25,000 صحابي توفوا من اجل
الحفاظ على هذه الامانه وجيل بعد جيل حافظ
همم حافظت هذه الامه على هذه الامانه
كونها هي المدخره لكي تكون عاصمه يعني
العالم العالم
باختصار عندما يتحدث الجميع على ضروره
الحفاظ على الوضع القائم ما هو هذا الوضع
القائم باختصار الرجاء
يعني الوضع القائم كان هناك تفاهمات على
ان الوضع القائم هناك
وصايا اردنيات تقوم هذه الوصايه على ان
الاوقاف الاسلاميه في القدس تقوم على
اداره المسجد كامله
والشرطه الاسرائيليه لها السياده الامنيه
وليس لها السياده الاداريه ولكن منذ عام
2000 وبعد اقتحام شارون حاولت سلطات
الاحتلال ان يكون لها ايضا سياده اداريه
تتدخل في شؤون همم اداره العمل في شؤون ما
يجري في المسجد الاقصى وبالتالي بدات
تتدخل في ادخالها المقتحنين وفي زياده
اعدادهم وفي زياده الرموز يعني اليوم هنا
حينما يدخل عباره عن وزير على مستوى وزير
يمثل سياسه هو دخل كونه غير وزير والان
كوزير غدا ستاتي الحكومه كامل الحكومه
اليمنيه المتطرفه بمعنى بهاء القداسه هنا
بالتالي تغير الوضع القائم الذي كان متفق
عليه وبالتالي نحن امام خطوره كبيره جدا
يعني هنا التحدي التحدي ليس الفلسطينيين
هو التحديد امه الاسلام كبير امانه هي
امانه اسلاميه شكرا لك شيخ ناجح بكرات من
القدس شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
تعددت الاسماء والالقاب لكنها جميعا تحيل
على مسمن واحد هو اسطوره كره القدم
البرازيلي الراحل بلاي الذي لم يكن اسمه
انما اسمه
الشهره غلبت على الاسم الاصلي لان الناس
لم يتعلق بهذا الرجل ولا باي دائره من
دوائر الانتماء الا من حيث مهاراته
المبهره في كره القدم
كثيره في السينما او الرياضه او الغنى او
مختلف الفنون من مجالات المعرفه ايضا لكن
المهمه ان تكون متميزا في مجالك
حيه في قلوب الملايين لسنوات طويله وهكذا
كان
ليله سعيده والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]